hey guys what's up welcome to Vlog
University I'm Justine and we are all on
a field trip right now did you guys know
that well if you didn't know that you
now know
that currently I'm in New York and I'm
so excited because I'm on the road with
Escape Routes we're in New York Rie are
you excited I'm so excited we're in
Little Italy I don't even know where
that is well we actually might know to
be in Little Italy yet either way we're
in New York woo this entire show is
pretty much over a month long packing
for an entire month trip was pretty
difficult this suitcase is full of
clothes cloes clothes clo clothes clo
clothes clo close closeth close close
close close Cheers
Cheers more
clothes girls I know you can relate so
last week your homework assignment was
handsfree so before I get into those
videos I'm going to give you guys your
homework assignment slsh showand tell
for next week which is to show me a
crazy Talent it could be anything don't
hide don't be shy make a video of your
awesome Talent submitted as a video
response to this video and if you want a
chance to win a prize head over to
escape scouts.com and submit your video
under challenges for their showand tell
challenge now on to some of the videos
from last week which was handsfree you
guys are absolutely
hilarious I didn't really know that you
could do so many things hands free it's
called handsfree cleaning can I get a
little bit of that handsfree cleaning
seriously only been here for a day and
I've completely destroyed this hotel
room isn't this great I don't even have
to use my hands I just kind of tell what
to do and it happens make sure it's
really clean don't miss that
spot so I think you cheated a little bit
because hula hooping you don't actually
use your
hands so this one actually creeped me
out a little bit I mean what if this
girl would have fell in her
face this next
video I'm speechless you pretty much put
all of the others to
shame who needs hands when you hold my
who needs hands when you hold my heart
and that's all the videos I have for you
guys this week I'm in New York right now
next week I will be in Atlanta and I'm
so excited because the first episode of
Escape Routes air this past Saturday and
if you guys saw it would you think I
love it I love you guys and I will see
you all in Atlanta be sure to stay tuned
on my iPhone Channel I'm going to be
doing vaa which is Vlog every day in
April so you can check that out here and
be sure to check out other I Justine
where I'll be posting Vlogs and behind
the scenes videos from this crazy field
trip I'm going to go see you soon
bye